- could you talk to us a little bit more
about your songwriting process like
could you take us through like one of
your songs the lyrics of one of your
songs and tell us about what your
thought process was as you were going
through it yeah sure I use a good
there's a good lender to talk about
lyrically but what the song wasn't a hit
but I really liked it it was called the
song is called darling Lorraine and it's
on an album called you're the one well
first of all it's like something that I
it's like my own private joke darling
Lorraine was a doo-wop song from way way
back so I often have little quotes so
doo-wop things anyway but I have a
musical you know setting and now I'm
writing lyrics so the opening lines of
songs are really crucial very important
I try to make the opening lines in my
mind to have this angle so that I could
you know as opposed to now that's the
end of the second verse and you have
nothing more to say other than to repeat
the first second verse and some other
form so this song darling Lorraine I
started it off with the first time I saw
her I could I couldn't be sure I don't
know what that was
but the sin of impatience which was like
a little note that I had written to
myself I put that in there but the sin
of impatient said she's just what you're
looking for okay so I walked right up to
her cliche with the part of and with the
part of me that talks little joke I
introduced myself as Frank another job
because I know the guy's a liar he's not
Frank at all from New York of New York
another joke cuz people from New York
never say I'm from New York in New York
I'm from Syracuse New York but you don't
say I'm from New York New York
intersects Frank from New York New York
she's so hot she's so cool I'm not I'm
just a fool in love with Darling
Lorraine cliche after cliche but I've
introduced characters Frank and Darlene
Laraine okay let's see the next verse oh
yeah so now I begin the next verse all
my life I've been a wanderer and I think
you're not gonna get away with another
verse of cliches so I immediately make a
turn and I say all my life I've been a
wanderer not really I mostly live near
my parents home anyway anyway Lorraine
and I get married and the usual marriage
stuff boom now we're moving faster I'm
not even getting into like what going I
did the usual marriage stuff and then
one day she says to me from out of the
blue Frank I've had enough romance is a
heartbreaker
and I'm not meant to be a homemaker and
I'm tired of being darling Lorraine okay
good
conflict here now what does Frank have
to say what you don't love me anymore
what you're walking out the door what
you don't like the way I chew you know
at which point my wife Edie said you
can't say that because people will know
that it's us I said that's every guy you
don't like the way I chew hey and let me
tell you you're not the woman that I
would you say you're depressed but
you're not you just like to stay in bed
a guy with a lot of insight it's like to
stay in bed and I don't need you darling
Lorraine Lorraine Lorraine I long for
your love so now the fight turns into he
just you know admits the truth now he's
kind of vulnerable so the next thing he
does is like completely change the
subject financially speaking I guess I'm
a washout everything is buy and sell and
sell and buy and that's what the whole
thing is all about if it had not been
for Lorraine on the left here long ago I
should have been a musician inside-joke
sure I should have been a musician I
love the piano but she's so something
for that she sells you so she's so light
she's so free I'm tight but that's me
and I feel so good
with darling the rain okay then the next
part of the song that I wrote had was in
a different key and the changes it was
so sweet it was almost sickening I said
what context what words would fit into
this context of so sweet so I said on
Christmas morning Frank awakes to find
the rain has made a stack of pancakes
they watched the television I like that
stack of pancakes I don't know sounds
good to me
they watched the television husband and
wife all afternoon it's a wonderful life
it's a pun pun on the Frank Capra movie
and also on their life it's a wonderful
life then what you don't love me anymore
what you're walking out the door this is
like a repeat of a love like a chorus or
something what you'll like the way I
chew hey let me tell you you're not the
woman that I Wed give me my robe I'm
going back to bed I'm sick to death of
you Lorraine and as soon as I wrote that
I said oh my god she's gonna die
then Lorraine Lorraine her hands like
would the doctor was smiling but the
news wasn't good last first darling
Lorraine please don't leave me yet I
know you're in pain pain you can't
forget
maybe I'll go down to the corner store
and get us something sweet here's an
extra blanket honey to wrap around your
feet all the leaves were washed with
April rain April was the cruelest month
all the leaves were washed with April
rain and the moon in the meadow took
darling Lorraine